There’s nothing cooler than Uncle Jessie
shades.
Except the Coolest cooler featuring a USB
Charger, bottle opener, waterproof wireless
speakers, and a blender.
This is episode 44 of LÜT.
Hit the road with GasPods on your car to reduce
drag and save money on fuel.
Thanks to aerodynamics
Then fuel your food with fire with alchemist
hot sauces - that come in seven different
flavors each in a hand-corked and wax-sealed
apothecary bottle.
But only hot sauce is bacon hot sauce.
Wash that down like an optimist with a half-
full pint glass.
Chilled to puzzling perfection in this Rubik’s
Cube fridge.
That actually has a warm and a cool setting
for keeping your food warm or cold.
If that doesn’t blow you away use the Hurricane
2 Canless Air System - that blows air over
200 mph without any chemicals, greenhouse
gasses, frostbite or explosions.
Just charge the battery and blow yourself
up a giant inflatable rubber ducky.
Swim with your ducky and listen to music with
the Neptune Underwater Mp3 Player - that uses
Bone Conduction audio transmission to transmit
audio through your cheekbone and into your
inner ear.
And it holds 4 Gigs or about a thousand songs.
Cheeseburger Mask.
For some incredible masks check out composite
effects.
They have professionally sculpted silicone
masks and gloves - and their mask lab let’s
you customize and test your ideas from skin
color and hair style to the scars, burns and
paint.
Mask the odor of your bathroom business with
the Poo Pourri Crapsman gift set.
It has essential oils that you spray on the
toilet water before you go - trapping the
odor without any harsh chemicals.
Odor yourself a deck of X-ray cards - to finally
see through your poker opponent.
See everything bright and smart with the emberlight
- a device that allows you to control any
dimmable bulb with your phone.
The automated lighting can turn on when you
enter a room, be set as an alarm, or be controlled
remotely if you’re out of the house and
left on the..
Lights.
Camera.
Action.
With your cardboard smartphone projector that
turns YouTube videos (like this one) into
grand cinematic events.
To improve sound quality while staying warm
the Audio Engineer’s Hoodie features acoustically
transparent, speaker cloth hood panels and
a headphone pass-through for internal wiring.
Finally, go camping with wires thanks to these
solar-powered tents - allowing you to charge
your devices while at festivals or amongst
wildlife in the great outdoors like the sloth.
The cutest of the deadly sins.
And as always - thanks for watching.